[Music]
every day somebody surprises me hi
everybody i'm lauren zima here to try to
solve a bachelor mystery and no we are
not talking about who Ari chooses in the
end this is a missing persons case
22 year-old Becca Martinez is a fan
favorite on this season of The Bachelor
and her mom loves her too
so much so that mom filed a
missing-persons report possibly
while Becca was on the show and yet here
you are so please explain that here's
the actual missing-persons report from
California it says Rebecca was last seen
on November 12th 2017 and we got this
statement from the Sheriff's Office they
say that at 1:00 a.m. on November 18th
about a week later her mom called and
reported her missing quote Martinez had
told her mother that she was going to
work on a marijuana farm and would see
her in seven to eight days the Humboldt
County Sheriff's Office attempted to
contact Martinez and other persons
associated with her receiving no
response
Wow okay the statement goes on to say
that Becca's mom soon actually told
police she did get in touch with Becca
later that afternoon and that Becca said
she was headed home but police never
made direct contact with Becca
themselves so she was never removed from
the missing-persons system and months
later we have this mystery but on
Thursday
Becca called the Sheriff's Department
that's what they told us she cleared
things up and now she's not a missing
person anymore
but this is still really confusing was
Becca actually missing
was she filming the show why are you
still here Becca tweeted on Friday mom
how many times do I have to tell you I
don't get cell service on The Bachelor
but if you look at the time line The
Bachelor starts filming in September and
usually finishes up sometime in November
so this is a little strange and unclear
was Becca in fact still filming the show
when her mom reported her missing well
it depends on how far Becca got with
Arie and maybe she doesn't want to say
so she's not giving a clear answer it's
also possible that she had gone to work
on a marijuana farm the show is not
commenting on this Bachelor
missing-persons case but it's definitely
a first for the franchise and ultimately
all that matters is Becca is
we accept us rest well what do you guys
think of Becca's journey on this
missing-persons case let me know over on
Twitter